pas d'une question biologique quand on
fait des heures 1971 sur le plateau de
post scriptum l'inceste est au coeur du
débat
la parole y est décomplexé les rires
fusent les invités sont à l'aise malgré
la gravité du sujet écoutez comment le
présentateur michel polac parle du film
de louis malle le souffle au coeur
l'histoire d'une relation incestueuse
entre une mère et son fils le problème
de l'inceste est abordé dans le film
étant donné qu'il a la chance ce héros
d'avoir une mère qu'on en rêve c'est léa
massari faut dire que non vie devrait
manquer la cesse dans ses cales alors
comment l'émission suscite un tollé
la polémique va même entraîné la
suppression du programme ensuite
l'inceste sujet tabou dans les familles
ne sera que très peu évoqué à la
télévision
les premiers témoignages arrivent au
début des années 80 comme celui
d'anne-marie violée par son père quand
elle était enfant à la seule chose dont
je me souviens assez que lorsqu'un mes
18 ans j'en ai parlé à un médecin qui a
un médecin qui l'a convoqué il a dit
écoutez monsieur ce sont mes faits et
j'en fais ce que je veux
il se sentait le maître le propriétaire
de ses filles et j'étais sa chose
[Musique]
al marri est l'une des premières
victimes a témoigné à visage découvert
1986 autre prise de parole l'écrivain
eva thomas parle de son vécu à
l'occasion de la sortie de son livre le
viol du silence bon après le lendemain
quand je me suis réveillé je j'avais un
trou noir dans la tête
un blanc dans ma tête je ne savais plus
ce qui s'était passé j'étais
horriblement angoissé mais je savais
seulement que j'avais le souvenir de mon
père sur moi et c'est tout à cette
époque le viol incestueux n'est toujours
pas reconnue par la loi
onze ans plus tard en 1997 la garde des
sceaux elisabeth guigou dénoncer encore
l'omerta autour de l'inceste
donc ces enfants sont là et soir y'a
personne pour les écouter pour les
entendre pour comprendre leur détresse
pour le protéger d'ailleurs parce que
quand ça se passe dans les familles
souvent la complicité autour de toute la
famille proche sont les drame
insoutenable en 2005 christian estrosi
alors ministre de l'aménagement du
territoire veut changer les choses
il propose d'inscrire le terme inceste
dans le code pénal
cette victime se réjouissait de cette
avancée moi je pense que c'est très
important pour les victimes parce que
c'est important dénonce un crime et que
les victimes en fait ce soir encore venu
en tant que victime d'inceste victimes
seulement de viol ou d'agression
malgré cette proposition ce n'est qu'en
2016 que l'inceste est reconnu par la
loi mais uniquement pour les agressions
sexuelles commis sur un mineur
[Musique]